I love the way Yanni is tasting
everything he's proven to be the rock in
the kitchen tonight hold on two seconds
off it
I'm not asking you to [ __ ] on your boss
he's standing there slicing the [ __ ]
rabbit it's gone dry there's two lamb to
be plated up and he's not saying
anything to you right next you cook
[ __ ] amazing food yeah but I don't
understand why you disappear in service
when you you don't talk to anybody so
I'm just struggling to identify who is
the leader tonight yeah yeah I want to
find the best restaurant in Britain and
the best rush in Britain doesn't have
food that sits on the hot plate for two
nine three minutes
we're on to desserts always a highlight
of great French cuisine true to form
Jean Michels created simple rustic
desserts including brioche pan perdu
with apricots Julie I'm sorry but the
chef check the desserts we'll use run
out with them well when he's busy like
that okay bizzy's only two tickets left
please show him the dessert a cursory
glance just doesn't do it you should
have tasted them they because aren't
ripe and they should never been used in
the first place that's why the chef seen
them an hour ago miss nothing going at a
kitchen whether you running a bistro
fine dining or a burger school you watch
everything damn what a shame I maybe
lose a point there with a really dessert
I think that the separatists could have
been much better there have been serious
mistakes in the kitchen tonight but
what's the verdict front of house it's
delicious here's a freshly my beverage a
driver and it's not like vegetables
they're really meaty for some party yeah
I love that it's fantastic yes it's time
for me to tell the guy exactly what I
think
at night weight off every restaurant in
every category is going under that level
of scrutiny it's a pressure test we know
as chefs that food shouldn't hang for a
long time on the hot plate I know I have
to think the blade for it the shoot of
the other path said and they did it
because I know they can do the job what
I did love downstairs was how often was
tasting stuff so when you run upstairs
with apricots
that the chef hasn't tasted I'm not she
to come back down and if you taste those
apricots before they left the hot plate
I guarantee you I said stop we're not
serving the pan perdu with apricots
apart from that friendly service bloody
good food they do things minute McGary
he's got great potential but it has to
be consistent on every plate whether
it's the most amazing starter or a
phenomenal dessert it has to be that
exact standard across every plate and
jean-michel has to decide if it wants to
cook all night long and past the leaves
you qualities to his number two and if
he wants to lead then lean if you want
to cook then cook